c'est ce qui s'appelle une fonte
accélérée 11 milliards de tonnes de
glace ont fondu en une seule journée au
groenland peut être l'impact le plus
spectaculaire de la vague de chaleur qui
a frappé l'europe fin juillet ce record
de température sur la planète
il s'établit à environ 1,2 degré au
dessus du niveau préindustriel proche de
la limite d'un 1,5 degré fixé par l'onu
c'est ce jeudi que l'on attend le
nouveau rapport du giec mais les grandes
lignes sont connues
le groupe d'experts intergouvernemental
sur l'évolution du climat va sonner l
alarme sur l'utilisation des terres le
rapport fait ce constat préoccupant mais
peu surprenant que l'utilisation
actuelle des sols n'est pas durable on
exploite près des trois quarts des
terres qui ne sont pas gelés sur la
planète
le rapport met en évidence le rôle
essentiel que jouent les sols dans la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
ils sont 1 puis pour le co2 émis par les
activités humaines mais dans le même
temps leur utilisation non durable est
une source considérable d'émission de
gaz à effet de serre l'élevage à lui
seul est responsable de près de 15 % des
gaz à effet de serre selon le giec il
faut massivement replanter des arbres à
l'image de ce que fait l'ethiopie qui
espère avoir planté 4 milliards d'arbres
d'ici la fin de l'année
certains y voient une opération de
communication mais pas ce spécialiste
des sols dubaï et les famines et la
plupart de nos problèmes sont liés à
notre gestion de l'environnement
sauf que ce n'est pas la première fois
que l'ethiopie tente de contrer la
déforestation mais qui
mini guide mais avec un succès mitigé 70
à 80% des arbres plantés entre 2000 et
2015 non pas subsister les experts
soutenu par l'onu vont aussi le
souligner dans leur rapport
la planète n'a pas le choix de changer
son régime
moins de viande et plus de légumes et de
céréales pourront nourrir davantage
d'humains tout en réduisant la pollution
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal